[Music]
okay good afternoon
just let me start with a question who
has ever flight by airplane here raise
your hand please okay that's pretty much
what I expected and now who is scared of
flying someone someone like okay I'm not
really scared but I get on the airplane
and I feel like something wrong could
happen maybe okay nobody well you are
brave here in Poland okay it's through
that aviation is the safest mean of
transport more or less everyone knows
that but unfortunately sometimes things
go wrong
things go wrong even if things go wrong
it doesn't always end up that bad and we
have to keep that in mind I will show
you here some examples of accident that
doesn't end up that that don't end up
that bad so these Boeing 767 landed in
Barstow Airport in 2011 with 220 people
on board without know without landed
year that means no wheels what happened
here okay
the pilot notice that the landing gear
wasn't out so he told that to the
authorities they sent a fire fighter
airplane for the from the Polish Air
Force so he could say visually if the
landing gear was out or not it wasn't so
what they did what did they do the
airplane started flying in circles
around the airport for around two hours
in order to burn out all the fuel inside
and in the meantime the fire fighters
were put in some foam in the runway in
order to let the aircraft land
so finally none of the 220 people inside
the air plan in their plane resulted
injured at all this is just one case
let's see another one
other things you might be scared about
flying is having some kind of fog jet
having some strike of an object on the
airplane in this case it was a bird a
big bird
but this kind of things are taken into
account since the beginning in the in
the design stages of an airplane so even
if that impact was really near the
cockpit the airplane could go back to
the airport and land safely I'm talking
about bird strikes strikes who doesn't
know this case which is the airplane in
New York which landed on Hudson River
what happened here was that this
aircraft was taking off from New York
and suddenly it had a bird strike in
particular the this bird were Canadian
geese so pretty big ones and a great
amount of them so in this case they heat
the engines not the the cockpit and the
pilot lost the all the power in both
engines he had no chance to go back to
the airport and he finally decided to
land on the river in this case we cannot
say that there were no injures because
there were five severe injured people
and most of the passengers needed
medical attention after that but nothing
more than that okay so what we are doing
today is to look a little bit deeper in
this accident to put some numbers on and
we'll do that with Python
we are not so in a lot of code will feel
will be focusing on the numbers but all
of that is done with pandas and you'll
have the code after that so my name is
Alejandra Ceja smartos we are both
aerospace engineers
we are part of a group called arrow
Python which integrates people with
passion about scientific programming and
that analysis especially if it's related
to engineering or aerospace engineering
did you feel attracted about that don't
hesitate to come and talk to us
afterwards
well our professional activity is
related to helicopter simulator
development in the case of zoos and to
fly test that analysis in my case but
aircraft safety is something that is
present in every activity in the
Aeronautics sector is something you
really learn since the beginning of your
studies that safety is there and you
have to take that into account
always so now asses will talk to you a
little bit about the data race ok ok
Sally said before we're gonna try to
make analysis of data base related to
the safety in aviation in order to do
that we needed an open data base and we
only could find one from an American
agency the NTSB is in charge of analysis
every accident that happens to an
American flight or related to any
American in the world they polished draw
that that was our key factor for us to
choose this database is open it was the
only one we could find that was open
from an agency now let's start with the
data first of all we want you to make an
analysis of the safety of a flight that
any of us in this room could take a
flight there are many kind of aircrafts
there are helicopters there are small
aircraft so we wanted to focus on
commercial aircraft that is the one I
think most of us have ever taken
also this database makes a difference
between the incident and the accident
let's say the incident is something the
an event that could lead to an accident
but
did not luckily in an accident is an
event that caused at least an injure or
a serious damage to the aircraft or even
missing as we can see here so let's
start with the filter in order to get
the proper data in order to make the
analysis if we draw all the incidents
this is what we get here clearly the
base is the database it's American as
you can see and also I want to clarify
that here we are in the incidents we are
not going we're not going to consider
because bylaws you don't have to make a
report after an incident happened so you
will not be representative for our
analysis of all the accidents here we
can see of course it's an American
database so we have more there but more
this American fly a lot so there are
accidents all over the world in this
case we are we are seen all kind of
aircrafts from helicopter to our equal
to our aircraft all of them so we have
to do another filter and this is what we
get this is the accident that we're
going to be focusing during this talk
here is just the same picture but
focusing of America these are the
accident that we're going to be focusing
only Americans so yeah you're not here
no ok ok well now it's time to you now
it's Alice you're gonna start to try to
answer in the questions that we're gonna
be doing this talk to the microphone ok
ok so now that we only have the
commercial aircrafts and only the
accidents we might
we might feel like answering some
questions the first one could be which
phase of flight is the safest well let's
just have a look at the faces our flight
has if you go to the airport you go to
the terminal you go inside the airplane
the airplane is parked there then you
have some taxi that's the phase where
the airplane is going to the to the
runway in order to take off it will take
off it will climb until some altitude
and then we have cruise Chris is the
longest phase of the flight you will
have your meal there you will be reading
sleeping or whatever there and at some
time we'll start descending to the
airport we'll have the approach phase
and then we will land and taxi again
today to the terminal so which one do
you think is the safest and which one do
you think have most events okay I think
that if you had answered me probably
taking off and landing are the phases
that we are scared the most how them
that's right
there's landing we can see also take off
up there
and we have cruise right there but for
us also the surprise was to find their
taxi and standing that means the
aircraft which can go really fast and
really high when it's on the ground it
has a lot of events and also when it's
stopped we'll have a look at that right
now
but okay that's the only related to a
number of events let's see in each of
the events what happens to the aircraft
really and what happens to the people
inside here we can see the level of
damage the aircraft registered for the
events the blue one is destroyed
orange substantial damage a green
mineral damage and red none okay so we
can we have like two different groups of
of accidents those one damaged in the
aircraft followed like Landy
taxi again a standing take off approach
and well climb is more or less those
ones really damage the aircraft okay for
the landing we we could hope like that
also for the takeoff but again taxi and
standing it's a high level of damage to
the aircraft has anyone here have fun
event with the aircraft like standing or
taxing nope so let's have a look at what
kind of events we can have this happens
this is an image at Boston Logan Airport
I don't remember the idea but it's like
five years old more or less we can see
an airplane which is standing park there
and another airplane on the right which
was taxing and suddenly heat with the
wingtip they also natal double header of
the airplane so this is a substantial
damage to aircraft because it's not like
a car that you have a small crash and
welder crowd your car just looks like
worse no you have to go and have a full
revision of the aircraft because of that
so this is another kind of event which
could happen obviously this doesn't
affect two people so the aircraft is
important but we see that there are
events that highly affect the aircraft
but do they affect people here we can
see in orange the total number of people
unaffected by the event that's no
injuries at all and in blue we have
injuries and also casualties the main
conclusion we can learn from this plot
is that in most of the cases most people
survived or have no damages at all so we
can feel more relaxed right now and then
let's see what happens to the people who
suffer some kind of injury now in blue
we have the casualties and in orange we
have injuries both severe and medium
again we have like two different
kind of events those one having more
casualties than than injured people and
those one having more injured people so
doing take off approach climb and also
maneuvering the number of casualties is
really high and we have the other group
and there's one there which which for me
it's like a little bit it's race
estranged let's look at London London is
dangerous right we we saw a lot of
events during landing but we have to
take into account that what we usually
call London is not what is called
officially London London starts at the
moment that the aircraft it's like 50
meters on the ground and then when it's
on the ground the rest of the face of
the face before is called approach and
if we have a look at approach it's a
dangerous one we are flying near the
ground we have little time to react
so that's tangible once we are on the
ground things can go wrong we can have
an overrun we can go away and not stop
at the end of the runway we can go
outside the wrong way we can have a hard
landing but that's not that dangerous as
we can see here so now we were having a
look at the faces of the flight let's
see what leads to this kind of events
right now okay can you hear me now yeah
right now if I was a Judy what are the
most no surprise well the events that
happened the motoring accident suppose
you have two sources your own experience
I suppose most of you have ever
encountered with some kind of turbulence
during a flight and also you and I and
all we have seen many movies so we have
seen collisions and fire and all of that
so that's our what we think about when
we are thinking about accidents in an
airplane and the data says that you are
mostly right the event that happened the
most
is they in flight with incanting with
water that is basically turbulences and
also when there is bad weather with is
for example the ice formation is very
important to take into account for an
airplane or a helicopter and we have
also different kinds of collisions
collisions when you are in flight
collisions when you are standing like we
said before this is important to say
this is not the main cause of the
accident this is just an occurrence in
order to get an accident as you probably
know is not is necessary
beautifully more than one occurrence
there has to be happen more than one
occurrence to get into an accident
focusing we will see in more detail
these kind of events but focusing in the
one that has the most accidents in
flight encounter with water we can see
an example for example of a airplane
that has to pass through a cloud and he
found that cloud was full of hail that
is some kind of snow and this is the
result usually the pilots are trained to
avoid this kind of situation but
sometimes this happen and this is the
result obviously it's also designed to
to to surprise to these kind of events
and on the other part we can learn from
this database and from all of these
safety analysis that all the agencies
are doing all over the world and every
year is what we learn we learn that for
example the ice formation is very
important for for any kind of airplane
or helicopter so here we can see here is
a procedure that almost all the aircraft
in mass commercial the aircraft has to
do every day in country for example like
Poland where it's very cold this is a
procedure to avoid the ice formations
probably in Spain you're not going to
see this but in Poland you're going to
see this every day and this is basically
from from the experience we get or from
a database or from the experience from
the speediest now let's take a look at
the same event that we were looking
before but worthy cause in terms of
people injured this I hope the real
actual even more because if you see the
event that finished the most common
inflamed encounter with water you see
there are many accidents that that had
this event but if you look at the orange
bar that is the people that has snow is
the accident where there were not people
injured it's very big so there are many
accidents with with this event but the
result dust no one is injured so that's
that's important to remark and also I
think for example the we can see the
Efrain component malfunctioned this is
something that it also very common in in
a movie where a part of the aircraft
gets out and suddenly the aircraft has
to learn in a hard landing or something
like that but the reality is that
usually the total number of fatality
sees is not very big and now in this
graph is we analyze again the events and
we are analyzed in terms of damage to
the aircraft we can see that for example
one the blue bar is those aircraft data
completely destroyed the orange one are
those who are who has substantial damage
and the green one is mineral changes
manner of damage and the red one is
non-dimensional we can see that yes for
example the malfunction or
yeah we can focus on my function my
function generates a lot of damage to
the aircraft but as we saw before that
doesn't just lady to injure and that's
important in terms of safety and again
we have many factors in in order to take
a look we wanted to make a simple
analysis of fire to see how effects an
accident you can see the first column
shows how many accidents in how many
accident they were fire in the second
row grd that means it was fire on ground
and the second was fire in flight and in
the third one was not fire or what
obviously the first conclusion is that
usually in an accident there is no fire
so for the movies is very nice but the
reality is that are you sorry there is
no fire in an accident and also what we
can get from this data is that if that
is flight on ground the number of
victims is less why this is because we
have learned from this and the procedure
if there is fire close to an airport
lead us to to have better behavior so
pilots and the crew members they are all
trained in case of fire when that
happens on the ground obviously one is
in flight the limitations are bigger and
it's different
okay so here we come up with another
question
that's the 8th of the pilot has any have
anything to do with with the chances of
having an accident what do you think
because okay we could think that maybe
younger pilots are in a better physical
condition so they can maybe react
quicker more quickly to an event but we
can also think that a more experienced
pilot
maybe reacts a slower but he takes the
the right choice so what do you think
here we have the number of facts Eden's
registered in the database and the age
of the pilot both the pilots and the
copilot in the in the aircraft we could
be tempted to say that between 45 and 55
we have more accidents and that's true
but we also have to take into account
the number of pilots at it's 8 so if we
take the number of licenses for its aids
only for commercial aircraft ok this
doesn't include general aviation or any
other only for general aviation we have
this is a number so now that's with a
division we have the accident the number
of accidents divided by the licenses so
like an accident rate and we can see
that between 19 and 29 we have much more
accidents than than for all their pilots
we were like kind of afraid of saying
something that was wrong here so we
checked if someone else investigate
research about that before and we found
that some people have investigating this
issue before and they say that the
accident rate of airline transport rated
pilots aged between 55 and 59 is
approximately one third of that of
pilots with the same rating who are
aided between 20 and 24 this is more
the same we have maybe we could say that
we have da ville' there instead of one
third but is the data we have and so
kind of the same result so it does look
at your pilots when you go inside the
airplane okay so the last question we
would like to answer is is flying now
safer than it was before here we can see
the number of victims
we have fatal victims severe and medium
victims over the years what we see here
is that this is not an uniform data this
is like house events at some points and
Peaks for example okay here we have the
terrorist attacks of September 11th 2001
and okay all their fatality ours for for
aviation so we cannot extract any
conclusion from these from this plot and
we have to say that even if many
accidents many many accidents occur
every year not all of them have a high
number of victims so if the accident
involves RCM people Asian people or
European people it won't be registered
here however we can have a look at the
number of accidents which is more
representative because we can say that
the number of accidents can be something
like proportional to a number of flights
and then we will have a North American
flights we can at least use these data
to have an idea of what's going on this
is the number of accidents again we see
that the total number of accidents is
going down lately but we also have to
have a look at the number of flights
going on we also see that the number of
flights is increasing every year and
well just a little detail here this is
recession crisis not only as pay in
Poland and Europe suffered that so it's
there in American aviation it's not a
saying that the the data from the source
from this data was explaining a little
bit about evolution
so we have crisis there if now we
calculate an accident rate in accidents
per million flights we have with our
data that we are around for accidents
per million flight keep in mind that not
all accidents had victims even not
injured people so and also we have to
say that even if we can see that the
accident rate is decreasing here for the
last year the institution's looking at
aircraft safety are stating that we are
not evolved in that much so as this is
only partial data and we would like to
give you like the global official data
we can have a look at a essa which is
European aircraft European aircraft
safety agency sorry for that so it's our
official institution studying aircraft
safety and they say that the fatal
accident rate is around 0.6 per million
flights and non-fatal that means only
injured people or maybe the aircraft
substantially damaged but no injured
people it's around about four point four
so the global number would be something
like five accidents per million flights
okay until now that this is just like an
analysis of the current data but what
can we do in order to improve this is an
initiative of Vyasa also which is called
data for safety you know we live in the
era let's say of the big data that
analysis machine learning so we can do
much more than story in our accident see
now one hundred two hundred megabytes
database and they are talking about
analyzing safety reports with with
natural language processing they are
talking about using not only the data of
the accident but also the flight data
you know the the aircraft has an air
flight data recorder we could use that
data in order to compare it between
different
and look for some kind of anomalies
happening there which could lead to an
accident imminently or in the next
week's maybe we have also the civilians
data which is Rather's in the airports
and all that kind of stuff and also
weather data which is really detailed
right now so as some conclusions some
conclusions about our analysis that
analysis process is not a bed of roses
that's something you probably know
because we work on that but as data
scientist is like the most sexy job
position you can have right now we have
to say that a cleaning data and dealing
with wrong data values and all that kind
of stuff is not sexy at all fortunately
pandas help a lot in that process so you
will have the code if you don't know
about pandas or if you are just curious
about what we did you can have a look
there and thank you very much for your
attention we have time for one question
do you have any questions okay
if you if out of all those data analysis
you've done do you have some already
conclusions like what could be improved
what areas should be improved or
something like that any ideas that you
already have this is just if I have to
give you one recommendation would we I
mean this is just kind of a joke but
know that keep your seatbelt fastened
while you are inside the plane many of
the victims we see there are people that
during the cruise phase are wearing no
seatbelt at all
and suddenly maybe because of turbulence
or maybe because the pilot is forced to
do some kind of maneuver to avoid other
aircraft or whatever could happen they
go up and hit the ceiling the top of the
plane or heat another passenger or
something like that and that leads to
more serious injuries than we think
before many people is like joking about
seat belts on planes but I think that
one is important in a in a global level
I think obviously the place when you
always have better chances to improve is
where there are more accidents so there
are many things going around a
approaches and takeoffs to the to
aircrafts to the airports has better
navigation systems and better alerts to
pilot which can in order to be more
assisted during the landing so many
times the pilot has to adjust some some
buttons and he can only be watching
what's going on just in case he has to
take the control so that's improving a
lot and keep that going on will force or
improve this thank you for your
presentation and
[Applause]